they have celebrity voices for GPS these
days and it's a new thing you know it so
used to be just the regular voice but
now there's this there's this idea that
we can get celebrities to tell you and
you have such a calming voice that I was
wondering has anyone approached you if I
was driving in heavy traffic and stuff
was happening and Bob Newhart was with
me saying well you might want to take a
ride it would just be very calming and
reassuring well I know I've never been
approached but it's a lot but a lot of
people really like I think a great like
a great celebrity voice on the GPS you
know would be Joe Pesci wait you ain't
Joe Pesci would be a great one well
because Joe is kind of Joe is kind of
like intimidating yeah I know yeah so
you know so I I don't know I'd like to
because he's the great guy I'd like to
hear like yeah we coming up on it you're
gonna want to make a right here and
about about five four three two one make
your right how come you didn't make a
right
[Applause]
okay hit you could take this street and
take a right here yeah yeah this one you
miss it religious nothing I would still
prefer it if you did it I think would
calm me down he would have me on the
edge of mine let's take a quick break
much much more with Bob Mueller when we
come back cigarette
you